white again efore this time alrighty
let's go with this and let's go with mr.
Lopez right Lopez the Spanish opening an
oldie but a goodie ah the classical line
of the Royal oppas
what are you doing this case let's start
off with Castle I don't know I'm not
sure why but why not ok d3 or do I try
4d do I start try for c 3 and d 4 could
I really get away with taking the knight
in the pond
I'm afraid of that so I'm not gonna do
that I'm afraid of like well I don't
know exactly what I'm afraid of
but I was afraid of something just
didn't feel right
can I get away with just saying that it
didn't feel right so I'm not gonna do it
c3 and then d4 do I pin the night I
really don't know
let's try c3
let's see
Bishop a4 Bishop III actually maybe this
pin can be a bit annoying let me do this
first you might want to do this first
just to induce some weakness that
weakness being maybe h6 okay now with
this night being pinned let's connect
the knight it's more development in if
you're super new to chess being fully
developed implies the following having a
direct connection between both rooks
having them defend one another directly
so as soon as this Queen is no longer in
the back rank mission accomplished for
light sure what I want to do well maybe
I could go with this typical maneuver
this Knight f1 to g3 hit that Bishop and
then maybe do something in the center
after this pin is no longer I have
invested quite a bit of time already
well right now decision time for my dark
square bishop I think back up and try to
be a pain I guess ok so there's some
some weaknesses here I will not be able
to make use of g3 with my knight but I
do have the e3 square available and then
I guess I could try to pivot right here
this is definitely a bit uncomfortable
this pin that I am in right here let's
get out of the pin put pressure on this
night and then my queen is actually
facilitating this d4 advance I think I
think with this move I'm able to brake
in the center and this is really what I
would like to have happen right now
because these pieces are on the edge and
with this Queen move it doesn't well
black is working themselves into a pin
and with this next move coming up I'm
hitting that pinned piece so this can
definitely turn out to be very
uncomfortable for black it would seem
like a some a6 move or a 6 + b5 move is
going to be needed but we're gonna see
about that
well that's what we're having now but I
think a six is not the move to be going
with that that very moment because I
could just be taking I think after I had
played d5 that was the point to do that
now I'm I'm up a minor piece and it's
it's really going to turn out to be
feeling like more than me just beating
up a minor piece because after I have
this F 3 and E 4 structure this Bishop
and I guess you could also view it as
this Knight right here just kind of out
of play and to top it all off this rook
is now trapped
so the typical domino effect in chess
one piece falling others follow shortly
thereafter so I just want to not allow
f4 to be played I am up a full rook at
this point so let's keep things nice and
simple no need to get fancy so I'm gonna
go after this pawn and then get to this
square I guess that could be a good spot
all right and go here he's the last
piece that wasn't doing anything there's
about a minute lead for my opponent but
this is a significant material advantage
to be up a rook right now
I'm on this bishop okay
let's just come back I'm gonna come all
the way back the night is boxed out for
my bishop a bishop in a night let's do a
flight square a bishop in a knight that
are on the same file or rank with
exactly two squares separating them
often has that bishop dominating the
night so I'm just gonna watch out for
what where that night might want to go
might want to go to be for I guess it's
a maybe a bit unnecessary to be going
into defensive mode like that but can't
be can't be too bad just being extra
cautious and and now I just pushed that
a pawn to Victory Lane upcoming Victory
Lane discovered tricks got the rook with
check downhill right there we go
all right good game let's hit that back
button and flip the board here where is
there an improvement on for either one
of us I was really and you could hear it
in my voice I was just unsure of what I
should even be doing right here I was I
did consider maybe chopping the knight
and then this pawn doing it a move
earlier I definitely know that there's a
way to get it back like right here take
the knight recapture if I grab this pond
there's Queen here or Bishop takes pawn
first with Queen Queen to d4 type of
combinations but right here I might have
a way to actually pick up this pawn as
well I don't know is a little bit scary
for me but when with the slower approach
just getting in development and where is
there something I don't know that this
is okay how about this
the knight moves seemed is a bit off
taking it out of the center because if
I'm able to make a break in the center
and this this right here could be your
little I guess cue to know whether or
not it may be
it's a good idea to be running whether
or not it's it's not quite a position
where the center has officially been
locked up or closed and so I don't know
if getting into are considering the
maneuvering type of maneuvering type of
moves is best throwing it to the edge
and releasing control over these two
light squares I do get this d4 break in
successfully so maybe Bishop here and if
you wanted to maybe then Knight h5 to f4
real quick maybe this is where your
knight belongs I see the idea a knight
here so you can get f5 in but I make
that break so that's one suggestion to
maybe tuck the bishop back and look for
Knight h5 f4 and you know what maybe
that's a typical type of thing to be
running with because you know you make
these make these pawn moves you break
the pin and you could also view it as
you know supporting an eventual knight
on f4 you have two pawns there it's
tough to kick away and night I'm at f4
square a black knight on f4 because I
have a bishop on g3 and there's no pawn
to g3 move there as a result may be
moving your knight right away and at the
very least right here a six ends up
losing material so it's way downhill
from here I think backing up the bishop
and then if this move then then the a6
move gets played I think at the very
least I end up with a pond but it won't
be me being up a minor piece if you go
with just Bishop back pawn here and only
then a six
that'll be an improvement and hang on to
more material for black